[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going bros my name is beard
that's insane you ever said that
you ever looked at something and said
that's insane i had
that's an emotion i had i'm a human
being that's the subreddit we're looking
at right now and let's see
if we can recreate that feeling all
right that's what i want i want to go
that's insane that's insane if i don't
get it that's insane out of that
insane i'm gonna go insane get it good
joke
felix the topaz hummingbird is the
smallest bird in the world
even though it has the smallest bird
brain in existence
it knows that jeffrey god damn it i was
so close
i was just about to that's insane but
then no i got hit by an
outdated meme millionaire meets
billionaire
okay
that doesn't even look real why would
you need a boat that big
why do you need a boat at all
oh my god i want billionaires at least
to use their money
to do something cool with it not just
buy a boat god cringe
all right well i've seen this kim
jong-un's bodyguard protecting his limo
maybe some of you or guys are going
that's insane but i've already seen it
so i'm
going i've already seen it that's my
reaction all right what do we got truck
emergency brakes and his reaction is
getting insane oh it's norwegian
okay
that was too close i don't like that
that just makes me anxious
oh my god you idiot child oh god it
makes me so anxious i can't look at this
that's not insane that makes me sick i
can't do this subreddit
i can't do it studio apartment no thanks
you can cook a sandwich while taking a
and a bath
at the same time i'd say that's pretty
epic i'd go for it hey at least
you got all the necessities right i'm
trying to look at the bright side
so far i have not gone that's insane
which is annoying me all right what do
we got professional dancer kyla
shea's foot strength that's impressive
not insane
impressive all right come on this
russian
stadium didn't meet fifa's regulations
on capacity so they added
18 000 seats in the most terrifying way
possible
i've seen it god damn it what the
is this
[Laughter]
what
that's insane
yes oh my god goddamn cats
that's insane god damn cat scan god
all right i i've definitely been through
similar they just squeeze in
oh my god dude stop this is the man that
really wants to get the
home come on you're not gonna fit
you know they have people that push you
as well they help you like
there are actual employees that push you
in that's more insane in my opinion
the remains of astronaut vladimir camaro
the man who fell from space that's
insane
why does he look like an alien vladimir
i gotta look this up
it was the most highly experienced
qualified he was in the soyuz program
in 1966. the cosmonauts
knew that the spacecraft had major
safety problems
but if he refused to fly then someone
else would be
forced instead so he did it anyway
he chose to fly to protect gagarin i
guess that's his colleague
and insisted before the flight that his
funeral be open casket
so that the soviet leadership could see
what they had done
so he knew he was gonna die holy
that's why this photo is so insane
i was like why would they have open
casket oh whoa
whoa that is insane i'm so glad i read
into this
what a hero so he knew exactly
what was gonna happen
they were working 12 to 14 hour days
camaro was ordered to reorient the craft
with the iron flow sensors
the sensor failed that's insane that's
an actual that's insane all right what
else do we got
no i hate these it makes me so anxious
oh god
yeah you have dreams you have things you
want to do yeah forget about it a stone
can fall from the
sky and kill you at any point jesus
christ
it just it makes me sick a man named hh
holmes renovated a three-story hotel
specifically to kill people
it included stairways and hallways to
nowhere and a maze of over 100
soundproof windowless rooms he may have
killed as many as 200 people but only
confessed to 27.
jesus hey you got the high ground
he's got the event that she's pretty
smart why washing your dried chilis is
important
oh god is that rat where's mice
[Music]
suddenly i like very blind food how
about that wow
thanks that's terrifying
that's not insane that's terrify what
the
he's shooting them with a truck
i'm pretty sure that's illegal but okay
what the
[Music]
oh my god dude so he did this because he
was annoyed
by loud music all right
all right i'm waiting for that that's
insane
whoa that is insane
what how how i'm sure there's a vsauce
video explaining it
mountain lions really sounded like left
4 dead chief size
[Music]
cool i'm never going outside again thank
you so much will smith says
stay at home will smith's house no
way is that his house
jesus christ dude
[Laughter]
wise men wearing a scarf and a jacket
and
gloves in l.a there's got to be
photoshop what
i get the whole thing like yeah he's an
influencer so it's good that he tells
people to respect
it right but i say because he can
actually change people's mind but also
yeah it does
yeah that's a weird look man what is
that
no that is not real
that isn't safe
i don't want to share the earth with
that thing i feel
dirty oh
stacked pallets for the world's largest
bonfire in norway no way that's insane
that's insane that's so cool foot surfer
all right that's not insane but that's
kind of cool
oh hell yeah i want to do that oh god
not the spiders
yeah that's kind of cool i don't mind
the
furry one they're they're kind of cute
i'm not gonna yeah
but uh this is just like
death dude i don't want that thing ever
oh god it makes me sick dude what is
this and
powerful floodline all right let's see
it
whoa holy
i forgot to say it sorry that's insane
wow
this is the new yanny or laurel you will
only hear the word you're reading
re-needle i heard green needle and i
didn't read it
alright what do i hear without looking
at it
great definitely a green needle but now
i read it though what is the other one
brainstorm all right let me look at
brainstorm where they say
[Music]
that design what all right green noodle
what
that's insane how
[Music]
oh brainstorm it all
i kind of get the last part right needle
spray or green how's the start of it
[Music]
rain rain green rain
yeah i'm starting to understand it okay
yeah
not insane anymore that's kind of cool
though scientists claim
that future biotechnology could be used
to make prisoners feel as if they were
serving a thousand-year sentence
in a matter of eight hours drugs could
be developed to distort the minds of
prisoners
into thinking time is passing slower can
we for the love of god not do
this imagine some
oh god some guy in the street
hey how you doing enjoy a thousand years
this is straight out of i have no
mouth and i'm a scream dude
thank you scientist but no thank you
scientist
just stop scientist can you stop stop
stop it that's enough all right cure
cancer or some but not this we
don't need this
what is that real argentavis
magnificence
that was the size of the bird went
extinct five million years ago
that is if that's real that's so cool
this is called the giant territory
so people found phil foster something
it looks pretty dank that's a pretty
dank bird how how would that even come
to exist dude
dinosaurs aren't real i'm just gonna go
ahead and say it no way
i don't i don't want to share earth with
that it makes me too uncomfortable i
don't like it
no i'm done dinosaur's unreal
science
all right something positive please
lakers fan hits halfway court wins 100k
let's go champ
that's insane if it wasn't mr b's video
he would have won wayne way more
come on you got swindled dude on only
100k
yeah that's not that insane uh welcome
to saudi arabia the parallel universe
wow saudi arabia glad to see that you're
having a good time over there wow keep
it up saudi
proud of you well done well done good
job good job
ah that's kind of cool
all right the wreck of costa cordia
photographed by a tilted camera
that's insane that is so cool
is it cool i hope no one died or
anything but that's really cool
damn that's insane the three gorgeous
gorgeous gorgeous damn in china which
required
510 000 tons of steel to construct
and generates 11 times more power than
the hoover dam
it's so massive that it slowed the
rotation of earth
is that true maybe we shouldn't be doing
that
scientists can you stop you know we're
so right
we need to just stop okay i i think it's
important
dude we need to stop
scientists needs is that we're so many
believe the dam will ultimately
result in catastrophe some concerns
include the dam trapping pollution
spawning earthquakes and landslides
uprooting citizens more than 1.3 million
people
already forced to relocate the
government finally conceded the project
was ill-conceived
thank you so the shift in the mass size
impacted the rotation of the earth due
to the momentum
the moment of inertia that's so cool
and scary dad rushes into the track and
free his son from burning race car
whoa and it makes me cry when i cry it's
so
it's too much i can't deal with it but
it's so close to life and death i'm just
like i cannot deal with it
the level of details in this painting
all right damn it looks so real
damn yo
oh my god it's so
oh man that's so cool the oldest
surviving diving suit
strap up boys we're going it not no i
ain't going tonight
i think we'll scare sharks away yeah
the moon has returned to earth that's
insane
is that just a balloon blowing oh my god
after getting a cornea transplant you
can you get to see the stitches
damn that's insane eye
surgery i'm okay not knowing about that
that's a thing that might happen in the
future
thank you for watching that's insane i
hope you felt
that's insane if you did go ahead and
leave a like subscribe
why don't you and i see you bros
tomorrow got this
you feel the same way god oh yeah
if you want support the channel check
out the merch we got simp merch
tambourine merch mask merch we got it
all baby
see you tomorrow bro ah
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean